today's ceremony is a blessing marriage
where couples have been asked to attend
with crowns and ar-15 rifles as
religious accoutrements this is the
world peace and unification sanctuary in
pennsylvania
where guns are a symbol of their
christian faith
they believe these unloaded ar-15s
represent the biblical rod of iron
referenced
in the book of revelation needed they
say
to protect god's children we will now
remove our rods of
iron from the cases that have been sent
vertically
[Music]
this is a commitment ceremony
hundreds of couples from across the
world some taking their vows
remotely i made the condition of
marriage with uh
tanya tanya frilova she's from tula
russia
and we've spent the last nine months
communicating
on skype through and through google
translate
she's a wonderful person i mean she's
has a beautiful faith in god she's fun
she's light-hearted
[Music]
what you see here may look extreme but
it captures the anxieties
of the current moment about faith
and the right to bear arms
ar-15s are very divisive symbols in
america they've been used in a lot of
mass killings why do you think they're
important to have
in your church well i think there's a
lot of skewing in the media
um particularly when it comes to ars
there are more stabbings for example
than
deaths by ar-15 which is a rifle it's a
sporting rifle it's the most popular
rifle in
all of america also for women it's very
easy to control all
our queens in our community so to speak
are very capable with the ar
pastor shaw moon's father was a
self-proclaimed messiah
his followers pejoratively referred to
as moonies
known for their mass weddings often
between strangers
but after his death the church split his
son
forming a new one with pro-life pro-gun
pro-trump rhetoric growing some american
supporters
what is it about donald trump that you
think represents
your values uh you know he stands
against
the murder and genocide of 70 million
children in the womb
you stand again he stands against you
know
very radical left left wing ideologies
being pushed on our children
like mr trump many here claim america
under joe biden
would mean disarming people and a
descent into socialism
something he denies there's many cells
hidden cells all over the country
they're ready they're preparing
for some kind of war
to take over our nation
we don't want to become like venezuela
we need president trump to protect us
from many terrible things that might
come about
there is concern about possible violence
from many sides after a heated election
some here say they're reluctantly ready
to take up arms in defense
if needed are you
preparing or prepared for armed comfort
yourself
well i've taken classes and
i've practiced on a range
you think it's a serious possibility
that there will be conflict to the
results
not only do i think it's serious but a
lot of democrats
went out and got themselves guns when
they see what's going on with antifa
and black lives matter in order to
make a really an armed militia that can
really resist the government
you need more than just pistols you need
more than just shotguns you need at
least
semi-automatic rifles but you are a
faith that
wants to ultimately promote peace right
yes of course yeah
this is a window into the controversial
and extraordinary
but the fears they feel are part of a
much broader conversation in this
country
one far from resolved cordelia lynch sky
news newfoundland
pennsylvania